newly founded Football Club is rising to
stardom not because of the sport though
their kit has gone viral online demand
is so high that they have even stopped
taking new orders the fan owned Clapton
community Football Club wants to stand
up against fascism and designed the kits
specifically to honor this sentiment to
know what the meaning is be and what it
stands for it's a very powerful inning
to put it online the red purple and
yellow shirt is inspired by the flag of
the second Spanish Republic whose army
fought in the Spanish Civil War against
Franco's nationalists the back of the
shirt features the slogan no pasaran
meaning they shall not pass which was
used by anti-fascist fighters in the
1930s timing of the shirt coming out had
a big factor in its success I think it
wouldn't have felt so important to
people the fact that that's such a big
reply such a big response it possibly
you know says that people really kind of
needed this kind of positive message
they might not win the championship but
they've definitely won the hearts of
many fans around the world